hello look where we are back on the air
work work work work and never enter web
yes we're on the inter way and we're
going to ask the questions that I'm
going to I'm going to be the voice of
the people should internet host it
should internet hosting services and
tech companies be cutting ties with
white supremacist websites oh it or is
that a First Amendment violation now
that's an interesting question I mean
the ACLU supported the right of the
they're not going to anymore but they're
not going to anymore not me well I was
right and I think you have you have if
you have weapons indicate exactly what
happened oh and the Supreme Court has
ruled on this which is the difference
between speech and speech that is
immediately incitement so there's
Facebook for example has a
responsibility to shut down you know
Isis sites that are promoting Paris
attacks
the government has should should do that
I don't know I think we have to wait
until they have you know I don't think
that should be done right away in too
easily I'm kind of I think that the
solution to bad features more speech I
don't know I agree we agree and I'd also
just be want to know we want to know
what the hate group you think agree when
you show up with torches and weapons
right better position torches maybe to
the hospital at fuel you know set things
on fire okay gang teaching tiki torches
don't burn
I was inaccurate do you support
sanctuary cities to protect immigrants
from deportation yes there's a salt yeah
no I mean yeah yeah good but I'll remind
folks particularly on the other side of
the protocol so did Rudy Giuliani the
fact is sanctuary cities keep people
safer they keep people healthier and
they keep people educated for three
simple reasons you're more likely to
coordinate and collaborate with police
as a victim of crime or as someone that
was a witness of crime you're more
likely to engage and sending your kids
to school drop them off pick them up if
you're not worried about the teacher
being part of a deportation force more
likely to get an immunization shot if
you're not worried about a nurse being
part of a deportation force the vast
majority of cities and counties that are
sanctuary counties are safe
for the non cities and sanctuary
counties and so it is good sound public
politics and that's why Democrats should
stand up and stop eventually those are
the pragmatic arguments
there's also the moral argument yeah we
should let people into our country well
let me that's much more important I
don't worry about it it's look it's
being conflated it's not a shield for
criminal behavior and that's where Gavin
or I we should be really see that
there's also been research that fact
that finds the sanctuary cities act act
as a magnet that attract crime '''l
illegal to say if I move to that city
and I won't be facing these deportation
and certainly and there's Kate Steinle
from your sin and I yeah I know you can
know this case well her family would say
that the sanctuary side they have said
the sanctuary status killed their
daughter you got to be very careful
there and let me say this with respect
at the end of the day sanctuary policy
is nothing more than saying two things
one the federal government's job is
immigration policy the federal
government's job is the issue of
immigration and from a deportation
perspective from an enforcement
objective local law enforcement jobs to
keep people safe and that's when life
I'm asking local law enforcement that
when you're letting these people out let
us know that we can we were done by the
way as I mayor are not making the
argument nurses and teachers and people
in this in this private space should be
acting as deportation force if I think
that is not well I don't know serve
advocate that I think that's an
exaggeration or the new music alright is
it for jackbooted thugs and that's not
true okay
it just it this is where this this is
complicated cities all across the
country actually do coordinate with with
ice and ice it's got backlogs for for
decades and so the fact is that's that's
not what the issue is about the issue is
about the fundamental framework of
allowing local government the
opportunity to choose its most effective
public safety programs and not having to
dictator the federal government to tell
us how to do our job okay and that's why
I'm sanctuary pond well I don't three of
immigrants and just want to say two
things one I think it's very unfair that
this side of the panel is much
better-looking than this side
I did my part I want some a fat [ __ ]
than I want again we go so far it only
do so much you got to do your part a
little hit bill yes I would to locket
look okay so into our conversation about
the Democrats winning election yes could
they get a frank once could they get
somebody who would teach them to name
things better sanctuary cities yeah it's
not a great single-payer yeah confuse
not helpful make people think oh that's
going to be me a global warming sounds
nice I actually the Jesus Christ can I
just name things better
it's what maybe we start with that
because they did have someone his name
with marquetry cities is heart is a
horrible turbidity yeah we used to be
cities of refuge now it's actuary cities
I agree we can find it could find
something that it's not about the USA
the whole country should be a thing so
syphilis France originally exercise I
our mom a real mongrel probably from
Newfoundland which is just a euphemism
for stupid but I'm yes all those people
up in the frozen north the club seals
those are my people okay
I do feel and by the way what did you
think of Ray more getting more votes
than Trump's candidate Luther strange in
the Alabama Senate primary I mean that's
really inside baseball but rain more was
the used to be the Supreme Court of
Alabama judge who refused to move the
Ten Commandments from outside the court
yes there's ideologues in them is
actually like a very sort of muddled
case and that it's not really a test
case for Trump versus the establishment
because both Trump and the establishment
we're supporting strange I think Mitch
McConnell would like something like
fifteen million dollars into his
candidacy and on the other guy one on
the strength of evangelical voters so I
don't think it really tells you very
much about Republican politics John all
right one kind of thing in case anyone
on the panel is thinking of running for
president
I just want to thank because you're
running for governor
yes yeah in 2018 so so say your your
governor in 2018 now this is this is the
sixth biggest economy in the world it's
very 2/5 and it's really ok and we're
sort of the leaders of the resistance
and Trump is becoming less it's it's
probably be a pretty good platform if
you if a person was thinking I just want
to say chris Christie waited too long
Barack Obama when he ran they said
you're doing it too soon
always err on the side of doing it too
soon because the more you wait the more
[ __ ] they are going to just make up and
isn't that true Christie could have had
the nomination right and he was like no
I'll wait til next time and next time
was after Bridgegate man you remember he
didn't wait his turn in it that's right
you don't wait your turn if America has
proven anything they'd like a fresh face
they might do it why you're sure you
know just what a good voice of a baby is
[Applause]
all right thank you everybody
you